all right i know people are very worked
up for hatred mail this week
let me remind you what hatred mail is
[Music]
it's like email forwards from your
racist
grandma on steroids
mail written by patriots who hate david
pakman
because america and because
freedom so like with many hatred males
there really is no way to introduce what
we're about to hear
let's just listen to it together and see
if we can figure out what it means
i thought the david bachman was a
serious channel
well david pakman is a [ __ ] you can't
really argue on that point
he must have kidnapped tortured and
murdered at least 20 to 30 black people
to gain this level of white guilt
it's incredible pac-man is such a slow
[ __ ] and you
fans are [ __ ] stupid david pakman you
are
complete garbage is ruined by your
reputation this time
and obnoxious no problem perpetuating
falsehoods to advance your own narrative
fake news i have never been accused
of murdering anyone never mind 20 to 30
people
never mind 20 to 30 black people and i
would encourage this person to defend
that claim if he can
i would expect that type of thing said
about pat
but to hear that i am accused of murder
this is really quite low and it's i find
it
obnoxious as the person yeah and you are
complete
garbage as ruined by your reputation yes
uh my garbage has been ruined by my
reputation or vice versa not exactly
sure which one of the two uh turn
patriot mail into something positive we
have a coupon code it is hatred 40 and
it will save you 40
off of membership davidpakman.com sign
up
coupon code h a t r i o t
four zero and you will save just like
that
forty percent off of membership